each of these discs is a wafer of
sapphire they're about to be coated with
the Wonder material graphene a layer of
carbon just a single atom thick
this process being pioneered at this UK
company has the potential to
revolutionize microelectronics imagine
computers with graphene chips 50 less
energy a thousand times faster so it
really is a transformational material
despite being well funded with an
expanding list of clients the head of
this company has a problem how to stay
here I think one of my biggest fears
over the next few years is that we're
going to have to move the business quite
rapidly off the shores of the UK and
that's because there is more support
there is more capability for us to grow
in other countries these are the world's
first graphene-based electronic chips
and proof the UK can take a breakthrough
from the laboratory and turn it into a
technology that won't just generate
growth and jobs for potentially change
the world yet companies like this also
illustrate how the UK is failing to
create the environment in which small
Science and Technology businesses go on
to be world leaders I want to you
combine our technology and science
Brilliance with our formidable Financial
Services to turn Britain into the
world's next Silicon Valley
the chancellor championed science in his
budget protecting research and
development funding from a much feared
cut the sector will be relieved but to
become Silicon Valley the UK has to take
its breakthroughs to the next level it's
not just about big brains aching with
knowledge it's not just about people
kind of coming up with discoveries it's
then about creating a kind of pipeline
where that knowledge and the technology
and the expertise can be made useful to
companies and to Public Services into
society
realizing that vision isn't just about
throwing money at science the UK doesn't
currently have a Silicon Valley
investment culture government-backed
Innovation hubs have yet to prove their
true worth
Technologies like graphene computer
chips are set to transform our lives but
whether they'll be made in Britain
remains a question Tom Clark Sky News
Cambridgeshire